you're more likely to divorce if you met
your spouse this way new study says it's
a best life article it's hard to find
love especially the middle global
pandemic but singles
out there should be cautious if they
want their relationship to last how you
first cross paths with your partner may
correlate to how long you stay together
new survey from uk's marriage foundation
ask people who are or have been married
how they find their first spouse on one
increasingly popular method of dating
seem to predict a brief marriage about
around 12 of couples who met online were
divorced within three years of marriage
compared to within eight percent who met
through school six percent met through
work three percent met at a bar or
social outing and two percent met
through friends and family
in the survey 28 of respondents who got
married for the first time in 2017 later
said that they met their spouse online
tied with the other most popular answer
meeting through friends and family
interesting the numbers right there 12
who got a divorce met online
compared to eight percent through school
six percent through work three percent
at a bar social outing and two percent
through friends and family which means
the highest likelihood of a marriage
working out is through friends and
family yeah notes
i'm going to come only to you so tell us
what do you think i actually love this
story i don't know i mean tell us why
you would yeah because i'm looking for a
good referral fee right over there so
just to recap this
they they list the top five
uh best odds you have for your
relationship working number five last on
the list is meeting online
right because online it's all a facade
you're gonna put your best pictures up
there you're gonna you know look your
best how many times have that people
seen a girl online and then you meet
them in real person you're like yeah
yeah let me get the hell out of here
but uh behind that is school or above
that is school
work
at a social uh venue borrow club but the
number one place to get business or
relationship is a referral hey i've got
someone for you someone that i think
you'd be interested in it's amazing but
it's still the most popular is that
crazy right now the most popular way to
meet
right now is online
tied with a referral from your friends
and family is that crazy why is that
crazy i i just what do you mean is that
crazy okay are you on any of these
dating sites or no no comment however
um
the
first of all
what are you talking about
in his office adam has the five
different dating sites he has a calendar
set up on which one the biggest closing
ratio yes but so on all these
numbers in today's world did you mean
people are not going to use dating sites
of course they are yeah of course they
of course are just this i'm surprised
no i'm not shocked
it's more this is how far we've come
since covet is that
we all remember a time where being on a
dating site was kind of weird
on the internet but now it's number one
your longest relationship how did you
meet her not the name how did you meet
her pretty much any girl i've ever met
has been in a bar at a club bar but but
but i get it but which one was it your
friends longest relationship like have
you had a girl that was your friend's
girlfriend's friend or your friend's
friend a referral yeah a referral yeah
that happens from time to time okay but
i'm asking you your long-term
relationship i met her at a at a bar at
club live okay so that's second how
about the second one
um online online yeah and that lasted
how long two years how about the third
one
uh college college
yeah and college was what you just met
her in college
oh you know but was it friends like was
she a friend of a crew it was a friend
of a crew and yeah that was really
through a friend though but that's not
college that's a friend right so
yeah so i you know
this kind of makes sense though this
kind of makes sense and you meet
somebody through the internet so what
connections do you have to know the
history of this individual and then
eventually you date 6 12 24 36 months
you're like i really didn't know all
this history of course now everything
comes up out of nowhere i don't know if
i was ready for this versus if you're
dating somebody through referral and
they ask hey what do you know about this
girl what do you know about this guy you
kind of now know a little bit more and
you have to decide for yourself whether
i'm willing to take that risk or not you
know this guy's been single for this
long this guy's been this this guy's
been that you bring up the word risk
because it's all risk reward it's all
about odds you talked about this when
you when you talked about uh the book
that you recommend hundred and eight one
questions to uh questions before you get
engaged it's all about
playing the odds and it's interesting
this is why i think this is it's a it's
a numbers game i mean 50 of all
relationships end in divorce those are
marriages yeah that's how many how many
relationships people have before they
get married 10 on average i would say so
90 of relationships don't work to begin
with so if the relationships and you
want to have a successful relationship
to stay married and be together with a
person it's all odds and basically the
odds are basically saying
the more likely you are to meet online
the less likely your relationship is
going to work so we'll see
how long have been people meeting online
for 10 years maybe yeah dating apps how
what's your experience with these dating
apps kai you're a good uh i think
there's two things on this which again
i'm more on pat's camp it's not
surprising i think that with the with
the apps where it's more gamification
where it's more like it's it's
superficial and it's just there's
endless options in a sense i think that
that kind of makes people um
have a more if it gets rough or if it's
challenging and more like ah screw it up
your
and then the other one is in terms of of
um with with the apps i think it it can
start more casual as opposed to like
you're building a solid relationship or
your friends and then you kind of refer
someone or something like that where
it's more in common and then you build
on that i think here it's more it starts
casual and then it kind of just well
folks if you're listening
let's talk to some people who are
married uh so if you're listening to
this folks how many of you
uh if you don't mind putting how you met
your husband okay you have to be married
or wife how you met your husband or wife
and how long you guys have been together
let's see how many people have been
married how's that somebody put we met
online yeah i saw that no not just
somebody few people pulled but i'm
curious to know how many people met
online uh and how long they've been
married uh because that does kind of
make sense when you're meeting somebody
it's like quantity versus quality right
if you're if you're playing the online
gym you're playing the quantity game if
you think about it because you know
you don't really get 17 referrals from
your friends okay hey okay so listen i
got excel spreadsheet here's the 17
goals i got all their heights their
degrees their parents they're the type
of person that would deliver something i
would deliver something like that for
you with an excel spreadsheet but the
point is when you're playing this okay
let's take a look at what people are
saying i don't have a girlfriend
what does it say younger sister
[Music]
work five years i met my wife when i was
nine years old at church okay legit
uh uh 14 years she's a friend
she is a friend's younger sister okay
bar eleven years in march instagram five
and a half years mildred johnson
interesting so that one i'm married for
a year and been with her for four years
tinder app two years through friends ten
years online facebook three years friend
of a friend nine years married the beach
good for you michael holland five years
met wife in high school been married 25
years j dog
met wife on myspace
married 12 and a half years first of all
willie says he met in the club married
for 26 years holy moly what club was
that so i had arranged marriage somebody
said that where do you see an arranged
marriage uh the seeker 2020. i love that
10 years your conference
what
danielle
daniel
danyuk met 10 years at my conference
okay well daniel i'm glad you met your
wife at my conference
my wife passed away december 19 2019 so
i'm going to love you okay uh
rest in peace nightclub 10 years married
instagram five and a half years so look
at it you know kindergarten it's a it's
a different story everybody's got
different stories on how they meet but i
i see the stats and it makes sense to me
so does this kind of change your
strategy though adam does this change
your strategy because
you know maybe you're not asking for
enough referrals
maybe maybe you gotta ask i think you
should consider asking your mom for some
referrals here family and friends
i think i still think
um
i'm not shocked that apps are at the top
these days not shocked at all i'm more
just
surprised like how far we've come these
days that apps are the number one way to
meet someone these days it's more wow i
can't believe that but it's very real i
still do think the best
opportunity you have is just meeting
someone out how you doing
you know step to them
and just spit your game have some banter
because you think that's tell me what
your logic is behind i just think when
you meet someone in person
there you're gonna see how they act
you're gonna see how they carry
themselves you're gonna see how they
dance you're gonna see how they interact
with others you're to see how they treat
the staff around them again the internet
you're only going to put your best
pictures online you're only going to
like
there's been a time i've actually never
really met up with i've been talked to
girls online
one time i met wow this girl's super
cute brunette bruh i'd like that okay we
facetimed i go like this oh hey she goes
oh oh do i do i not look good i go no no
you look you look you look great i'm
just
did not look anything like the picture i
was like i gotta i gotta go and for a
couple days she's like i'm sorry i
didn't have makeup on i was like no it's
cool baby you're great i'm just not
feeling well whatever whatever excuse me
but you're gonna know she's listening
right now it's fine
you're gonna know
when you meet someone out
in public you're gonna know
exactly they're gonna know what they
smell like how they look how they
interact how they wear their outfits
eric's gonna obviously judge if they get
a booty or not like you're gonna see
what's up online you're not gonna know
and you're gonna maybe wasting a lot of
time and lots of energy and something
you're not gonna be with you're gonna
know
like a girl will know within five
seconds of meeting a dude whether she'd
sleep with the guy you've heard this
before right they're gonna know and then
obviously it's on you not to [ __ ] it up
but a guy is gonna
like a guy will not even go talk to a
girl
if he's not into her like they're not
even gonna waste their time hey what are
you wearing no so some guys are are less
less picky than others but still i think
the best way referrals
okay i'll give you another this i'm
going off on a tangent here the worst
referral the worst referral is from a
girl like a girlfriend
a girl you dated no no like a girl a
girl a female friend because they always
hit you with i've got the perfect girl
for you she's so beautiful
she's the best she's the funniest girl
and then you meet the girl you're like
yeah why are you wasting my time here
girls always hype up their girlfriends
have you not noticed that
they always think that their girlfriend
is the hottest the best the sexiest and
then you're like what the what the hell
was that
they think their friends are hotter than
they are have you not experienced this
no you haven't had that issue you got to
get better referrals listen it makes
sense while you're single so what i want
you to do is i want you to stay
committed to being single till 43 and
one day old i'm going to get married
after that right
at 42 and 316
the right age is 45 right 45 ish give or
take
i'd like to know from the crowd is the
best way to meet some person is just out
and about and step into them and saying
hey how are you doing what the what's
the outcome no the outcome is to find a
person to share your time with their
relationship so share your time with you
whatever you meet a relationship a
potential wife
sure a potential wife yeah of course
whatever gives you more intel and data
and there's a connection okay meaning if
the connection comes first
but i don't disagree on the connection
part but but connection long term that
doesn't keep the marriage together if
it's just connection you need way more
than just a connection part right off
the bat so so to me is the more people
know what kind of girl you're looking
for the more people are working for you
so if you enjoy this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]